私の個人的なやり方で言うたら
例えばここに四つの食べ物があって
じゃあ私には じゃああなたは先に一つ選んで食べてくださいと
僕はその場合はいろいろ考えちゃうんですね
何人かいるならば その人々の心を読んでみる
この人何が好きかなと
それで恐らくこの人はこれ好きだ
この人はこれが好きだ
そうすると残るのはこれだから
じゃあこれ私も食べようと
そこを読めない場合は
自分の体にとって何が一番損が少ないかと計算して
損少ない方に行っちゃう
それでも決断できない場合は何がおいしいかと思い
そこで決める これは番目に来るんです
ですから 大体そんなバカなことは普通人間はやらないんですよ
めんどくさいんだから
ですから やっぱりこの無常の真理を知ってると
別に面倒くさくなくて
それは普通の生活になりますけどね
人間っていうのはそうじゃなくて
四つがあったら一つ選べと言うたら
やっぱり美味しいものを選ぶし
まあそういうことで 生命としてはいつでも我々にある
罪といえば 不善といえば欲なんです
いつでも 次にちょっと説明しすぎでしたけどね
ディッティ ディッティはちょっとややこしいんです
ディッティっていうのは見という字書いてるんですね
見っていうのは間違ってる考え方という意味なんですね
いわゆるこれこそと私はこれで行くぞという感じで
何か掴まって意見 生き方をとることなんですね
それどうしても理解できないと思うならば
あとで説明します 簡単な方
で 欲から生まれる 例えば何か私は神様体験した人に会いましたよと何か言われちゃったら
やっぱりこれこそだと
他の人の話は聞きたくなくなっちゃうし
欲から生まれるんです
欲からではなくて 欲と一緒に生まれるんですね
妄破とはもう少々違う
妄破っていうのは まあ当然本来的な愚か者だから
別にそれでそれで終わりますけど
ここはそうじゃなくて
いろんなものを聞いたり感じたりして斬り入っちゃって
あ これこそが正しいんだ
これこそ道だとかと決めつけてしまっちゃう
そこで私はディッティはちょっとたまにみんなからかって試したりする場合あるんですね
たまに僕に聞くんですね
まあだから仏教ではやっぱり肉
魚は食べてはいけませんでしょうと
別に食べてもいいんですよと
言ったらいきなり と言っても
あなた方は殺生してはいけないと言ってるでしょうと
はい そうですと 殺生してはいけないんだったら
肉 魚食べることも殺生です
別に私は殺してないんだからと僕は平気で言うんですね
平気 そういう捕まれるように
あなたは殺してないんだからと言って
それで食べていいわけにもなりませんと
誰かが殺してるんだから
まあそういえばそうですねと言うんです
だからもういけませんと
肉 魚食べるなと言うんです
向こうには結論出せるように僕は情報を作ってあげるんです
あげた通り 僕は まあそういえばまさにその通りですと
でもあなた方の方がもっとひどいんだと
なぜならば 私たちは食べてる肉なんかは植えても水に入れてもまた生き返ってこないんだと
もう死んでるんだと 腐るしかないんだと
肉でも魚でもそうでしょう
一旦 これをもういくら水の中に入れておいたって
もう腐ってしまう でもあんた方が食べるご飯やらジャガイモやらちょっと水の中
土の中植えてみてくださいと
ちゃんと元気で生きてるんだと
あんたはいっぱい殺生してるんだ
だから野菜も食うなと
ご飯も食うな 僕は言うんですね
殺生は良くないんだったら
いいでしょ 殺生 こっちではそれほどやってない
あんたはもっとやってる
野菜も食うな ジャガイモも食うな
キャベツなんか食うな
豆とかね もやしとか食べてるでしょ
言ったら反応はどうですかと
そう言ったっても 人間は生きているためにはあーだこうだ喋るは喋るは
それは何ですかというと
これなんです ディッティ
僕はただただなんか猫を寝そべりなんか取っちゃったら
まあもういろいろ遊んで
別にどうしたとか 大した説法でもなんでもないんだけどね
僕らの立場から見れば
でディッティの方がそこで明確にディッティ
自分の好き嫌いで自分本位で肉と魚とか食べるなと思ったのは
その人の勝手で いい加減にいろんなことを自分勝手に解釈して
そこでそれでもご飯食べてはいい
ほうれん草食べてもいいと
大豆食べてもいいと もう自分の好き勝手決めてるんですね
だからどっちにしたってもディッティはディッティですよと
別に洗脳しているわけでもない
なく ごく普通の愚か者のもう一人だけなんですよ
こんなもので決められるものじゃないんだから
仏道っていうのはちゃんと無常ということを理解して
どんなものかと無執着な心で生きることしかいないから
分かったもんじゃないんで
その世界は ただ格付けちゃって
仏教だからもう何主義？何？菜食主義だよとかね
精進料理しか そういう人もたまにいるんですね
私は別にそれはそういうあんまり近い付き合いといっても
たまに会う人々が他にいなかったら
やっぱりあんた方は仏教だから
やっぱり菜食でしょ？あんたも
僕はいきなりそうですよ
その時僕は嘘を言っているかというと
全然そうじゃないんです
そういうふうに そうですねと
また次に食べるものは全部ニワトリかもしれませんだけど
菜食主義ですよ そこは何かいうかと
別に食べるために命のことをいちいち考えて
あーだこうだそういうことではなくて
もう食べられるものにはもう食べられるものを食べてるだけだから
そこには肉でもなく魚でも野菜でももう生き物じゃないんだから
もう 食べる瞬間にもう命はないんだからね
ですから別にもうそんなくだらない考え方はなくてもいいということで菜食主義ですよと
なぜならば この菜食主義の人々はわざわざと選んで選んで
ある生命を選んで選んで食べてるんだから
それは殺生なんですよ
僕は別に選べないんだから
もう何かあるものは持ってこい
それでいいやと 何でもいいんだからと
食えれば エネルギーの交換だから
まあそこのまあこういう言葉の遊びはどうでもいいんだけど
ですから 人間が自分の好みによって
これは道だ これは生き方だ
これは真理だとかね 一つしがみついて何か決めちゃう
ディッティというんです
見というんです 心は自由じゃないんです
そこで何か決める場合は
ほとんどこの欲で決めるんです
例えば いくら仏教の話を聞いたとしても
たまにキリスト教を信仰している人々が来ますけど
いくら合理的に喋ると
なるほどなるほどと言いながら
最後にやっぱり私はこういう何とか何とか 10年間も教会に通っていて
どれぐらい勉強してきたんだからとかとか
その宗教からもう解釈しようとする
僕は別にそういう人は捨てます
切り捨ててますけど そこでやっぱりそれは頭ではなくて
もう仲良くしていて 神父さんとすごく仲良くしているんだとかああだこうだとか
やっぱりその欲があるんですね
教会は雰囲気が良くて
いろんな人々が来るんだから
かっこよくて なんかもうこんなちっちゃな何人かのグループのところに来たってもね
そんなに支えは何もないし
そこでまあ あの欲に基いて
ああ クリスト教はやっぱり捨てにくいというだけであって
もし合理的にこういうわけで
こういうわけで こういうわけで
やっぱり神様は確実にいるんだというなら
僕はすごく真剣に聞いてあげる
なぜならば その人 それなりのしっかりした立場が持ってるんだから
そうでもないんですね
訳聞いちゃったら よくお世話になっていたんだとか
勝手にしろとか まあどうせもうろくな性格じゃない
もう仏教にはごめんだと
そんな性格の人です ですからディッティってのはそういうものです
だいたいこの日本の社会でこれはよく見えるんですね
何か一つ決めちゃったら
もうそこで目がね 尺度が小さくなって
そればっかりやっているという性格ありますね
それはディッティの性格なんですね
例えば あの何とか麻原さんのグループに入った人々は
これこそ真実だと 全然理屈も捨てて
世の中の常識とはもう比べることもなくて
自分こそ正しい これこそ素晴らしい
素晴らしい それに一方的に言ってしまっちゃう
そこで間違っているとわかっちゃったら
とんでもない間違っている
破さなくちゃいけない
叩かなくちゃいけないと
そういう風に逆になって
それまたそのディッティなんですね
そういうのは人間に普通にあるんです
ある誰かかな あのお経を信じていた人がとことんもうそこでお経を信じているということのお互いに憎み合うことは自分の宿業と思ってるんですね
けなすこと 憎み合うこと
もうすごいひどいんですけど
そこでもあまり居心地が悪くて
また自分で勉強して まあまあ日本訳ありますからね
中倉さん 勉強して この普通の元の仏教をやります
それこそ仏教 そこまで思ったのはいいんだけど
そこからお経の連中もやけなくちゃいけない
で そうなっちゃうんですね
そうすると僕らになんか教えてあげることも何もできなくなっちゃうんですね
私も気持ちよくなると思ってるんですね
お経に悪口を言った 言っただけで
僕はそれだけでは気持ちよくなるわけじゃないんですよ
人を批判するときでも
それは何か訳があって
役に立つことであって
我々の理解を高めることであるならば
批判してもいいんだけど
単なるそれは間違ってるんだから
やっつけます 全然もう悔やみも何もないんです
別に個人的な恨みあるわけじゃないんだから
お経について それは比較すると比べると
まあこういう風になりますよということだけのことであって
そこで見える現象がある人
まずお経を信仰していたんだと
そこでこれこそ正しい
これこそだして それで嫌になったところで
もう何他のこと見たら
あ いい これこそ正しい
これ全部やっつけてやる
そういうのは知恵の世界でも何でもなく
欲だけの世界でぐるぐるぐるぐる回ってるだけなんですね
ですから お釈迦様おっしゃっておっしゃった時も
そういう現象があるんです
ある 例えば ある人がジャイナ教から仏教徒になったんですね
お釈迦様 お釈迦様は考え直してください
考えてください もう一度
ずっと自分がある宗教を信仰していたんだからね
考え直してください 言っちゃったら
こんなこと宗教家は言いませんと
宗教家は私は信じなさい
私は信じなさいでも お釈迦様はもう考えなさいと言うんだと
そういうことはお釈迦様はしっかりしたことを教えることは確かですよと
ですから仏教徒になりますよと
何かなったんだなってところでお釈迦様は言うんですね
それはいいんだけど あんたは今までそういう人々のお世話になって
教えてもらって しっかりした性格を作った人間ではないかと
その人々を助けてあげたら
あんたですから 今からはその人々の面倒を見てあげてくださいと
と言うんです ですから
私はもう仏教徒になっちゃったんだから
ジャイナ教はもうけしからんだとかね
もうやっつけるとかね
そういう世界じゃないんです
今までお世話になって
それはそれで仏教の方が気持ちいいと思ったら
それはそれでとかね その柔軟性とこの大きさっていうのは
大体人間には大体はないことで
だから仏教をわざわざ教えてあげてるんですね
普通の人間にあるのはまず漏婆
それからディッティ 見
ですからこういう このみんなこの
かなり困ったりはしているんですね
ですから 私たちも哲学とかね
ほとんど見なんで ほとんどみんな専門見なんですね
自分に気に入ってるもの
理解できる 私は何々学問の何々とかなってるんだから
もう見に過ぎないんですよ
例えばフィロソフィーの場合
私はもう何々宗派の教えが好きですよとかね
フィロソフィーの宗派と言わない
スクールですね 学派 私はエンピリシズムの方が好きですよと
というのは その人にとってエンピリシズムはよくわかりやすいかもしれません
はい 私はプラグマティズムの方が
なんとかプラグマティックな
何とか何とかいうのが好きです
その人はその世界をよくわかって理解しているということで
気に入っているということなんですね
そこでもやっぱり見ですね
そこでこっちで漏婆とディッティで比べちゃうと
漏婆っていうのはもう入る対象はもう何だかんだ別に気に入ったものは全部受け入れるぐらいな状態で
そこでディッティの場合は受け入れるだけじゃなくて
そこで一つ一つ捕まっちゃう
で ちょっと強烈ですね
マーナは何でしょうか
マン この この悪い 不善心処の場合は強烈というとレベル低い
レベルが低くて強烈なものはかえって捨てやすいです
捨てやすいんです 例えば
まあ例えば私と喋ったって
私が何言おうとも それをまたケチばっかり言ってるんだから
もうやがてこの人と喋るのももう嫌だと
自分の心の中からも何も意見持てなくなっちゃってしまうんですよ
ということは 結局元々それほど根強くないってことなんですね
でも漏婆を捨てようと思って私は頑張ってる
それは絶対無理だと思いますよ
この人の漏婆をね 欲をなくしてやろうと
それはもう全く無理なんです
その人自分で修行しない限り無理なんです
もうディッティぐらいだったら
もうなんかちょっとけなしたらもう飛んじゃいますよ
で マーナも大体そういう風に
このちょっと強烈な汚れ
煩悩なんですね マーナっていうのは測る
比べるという意味なんですね
測ると 秤に入れて測るんですね
どれぐらいか それが測ること
マーナ パーリ語の同じ
これは動詞にすれば測るってことで
マーナティ ミナティという
[背景音楽]そこで何を測るかというと
我々は眼耳鼻舌身でいろんな情報
色声香味触法を受け取っていると
ある誤解が生まれるんですね
私は見ている 私は聞いてる
私は味わってる 私は 私は
私は どこから私はという概念が入り込んだかさっぱりわからないんだけど
それつなげてるんだからな
無常を知ってるない 知らないんだから
見たのは見たですけど
私は見たと どこから入るんですかと
音が入って聞いたと それでいいのに
私は聞きましたと それで私はという化け物が入っちゃうんですね
我々の内の中に ですから
眼耳鼻舌身から色声香味触法を受け取っちゃうと
確実に現れてくる化け物が私というものなんです
化け物だから実体はない
だから殺すこともできない
どうしようもない 殺すためにはいないと殺せないでしょうに
いないんだから 本当はないものだから
それは鏡の中に映ってる
ね 自分の映像みたいに
それ捕まっても捕まれないでしょうに
鏡に鏡を見たら映像自分見えるでしょ
捕まってみてください
猿だったらやりますけどね
こうやって 捕まったら捕まりませんし
捕まれません ないんだから
そんなこと ですから この私という概念が生まれてくるんですね
それは生まれたところで
その私を中心にして その情報を比べてみる
測ってみる そこはマーラというんです
もうかなりもう大雑把な煩悩なんですね
そこで測る場合も 私と等しいか
私より上か 私よりレベル低いかと
どっちかに測ってみる
どっちでもマーラなんです
この人と比べると私の方が偉いということだけはマーラではないんです
この人と比べると 私にはどうもダメですねとかね
絶対その人には仕えることできないんだと思うこともマーラなんです
だから高慢・上等慢ともう一つあります
用語で出てきます なんとかわからない
で 自分が偉いと思うこと
自分が他人と同じと思うこと
自分が他人より低いと思うこと
どっちでもマーラと見ているんです
それは結局は私がいるという概念から出てきている
とにかく比べることはマーラなんです
そこで我々の知識の世界
どういう世界かというと
とにかく比べる 比較する
チャートまで作ったりして
いつでもチャートが出てきます
経済学なんか見てください
比べる 比べる 比べる そこで本当にもうなんで経済学がおかしくなってるかというと
ここに学問的な比べ方じゃなくて
主観的な比べ方よく出てくるんですよ
例えば 日本の現代の人々の生活水準は何でしょうか？とか
何か馬鹿げた数字作っちゃうんですね
それで比べる アメリカとどうですか？スイスと比べたらどうですか？イギリスと比べるとどうですか？とかね
アメリカとスイスやイギリスの生活は違いますから
どうでもいいです そんなことは
日本には全然関係ないんだけど
比べたからって日本人の生活水準が高くなるわけでもないし
すごい好き勝手なんですね
ですから まあ確実にどうか分かりませんだけど
とにかくこの比べることは
たとえ経済学であろうが他の学問であろうが
我々はもう比べること癖がついて比べなきゃ理解できない
すっごい汚いんです これ捨てた方がいいものなんです
とにかく比べる 瞑想してあの人より自分が上か下か比べちゃいますから
そういう人はいくら頑張っても同じところを一歩も進まないんです
それ自体問題だから とにかく比べてみます
それすっごい苦しみの元なんです
生きづらいんですよ 比べる気持ちが入っちゃったら
あの人は上手ですよ あの人はああですよ
この人はこうですよ 私はこうですよとかね
だからみんなどれほど苦しんでいるか
全てマーラから生まれます
それさえ捨ててしまえば何のことないんです
私はもう12 3年も平気でこの服を着て日本にいたんだから
いろんなこと言われましたし
偉そうにみんな知識ぶり知ってる
そんな服装は日本は派手すぎですよとかね
落ち着いている国ですから
あんたはそんなことやっちゃった
全然聞かなかったんで
僕は もう言ってる連中は
たとえ教授であろうか
もうプログラム組んでないコンピューターだ知ってるんだから
何も役に立たないと もう全然誰にぶん殴られたこともないし
何も言われたこと まあいろいろ言われるんだけど
それはいきなりびっくりしてなんとか言われても
全然別に僕は気にしたことでもないし
いわゆるもう本当にこの嫌になるほど差別的なことは一度も言われたことがないんだから
別にたまたま何か言われたらそれはしょうがないですよ
当然ね まあ外人だから何か言われるかもしれない
それは別にそこでやっぱりまあこの人はこんな色だから
この人こんな色だから
やっぱりどうかなと自分がマナやっちゃったら
もう生きる生きていられないんです
勉強してた時でもいろんなことを言われるわ
悪口言われるわ 間接的にいろんなことやる
僕は何のことなく平気で座ってるんです
授業中でも まあたまにちょっとでもチャンスがあっちゃったらやりますけど
もう二度といないように
でもそれほどチャンスも得られませんね
授業中ではね で そこで批判されたんだから
私の心がすごく痛くなったって全くないんです
全然比べません 自分と比べない
この人はもうバカでしょうとか
それぐらいで終わっちゃうんですね
客観的に いわゆる情報見たら
この人の情報の判断はこれぐらいですよ
私と比べたらこれですよとかなくて
やっぱり結構生きやすいんですよ
マナだけマナでも捨ててしまえば
人と比べるんじゃなくて
自分にできることをやればいいし
できなければやめればいいし
すぐ比べる すぐ比べる
それはすごく難しい生き方だね
例えば障害の人が見えちゃったら
やっぱり気持ち悪い人だとすぐ比べる
ですから 何かしてあげることでもできないんですね
昨日かな なんかそういう精神的なそういう障害がある人
男の子がいてね 大体まあまあ私２５ ６
歳ぐらいだったと思いますけど
お父さんと一緒にずっといろんなことを喋ってやんなきゃやっていて
立ったところでいきなり私を見ちゃったんですね
何のことなく 頭をこうやって
で まあ僕よりは背が高かったんだけどね
で 僕はその人のね こういう目に入った途端
もうまあ どういう状態かって
まあ見えてるし みんなびっくりしたりするんですね
僕は何のことなく どうかと
こうやって僕はその人を触ったんですね
ても背中をたたいてあげて
その時降りるとこ見たんだから
じゃあもうこうやって
でもそこでびっくりしたお父さんも
もう何のことなく もう自分の息子を引っ張っちゃって降りたんですね
もし僕がこうなっちゃったら
そのお父さんにしたっても
やっぱり申し訳ないとかね
困ったと こんな息子でとかね
そうなっちゃうし そこはまたすごい良くないことであって
人間差別してはいけないし
自分と比べてはいけないし
ただその人の知識レベルから見れば面白いものだから
触っているだけのことで
だから認識するためにはたくさん情報を欲しい
それだけでしょ 脳細胞の障害あるんだから
たくさん情報だから触らない限りわからないというかね
だから触らせてあげればいいし
本人も自分も体触って触ってあげた方が普通
僕は人は触りませんだけど
でもその場合はその人にとってもいいですよということは
口で言ったっても理解しないでしょ
だから私も触っていると
それだけのことで 別に何のこともないんですね
もしまた二 三秒 二十秒でも時間があっちゃったら
もうもっとどうなるか私もわからない
お互いに触り合ったりしてコミュニケーション取っちゃいますから
次に必ず僕は知ってるのはこの衣を脱ぐとこれ珍しく見えるでしょ
だからそれ引っ張ったり脱いだりする
それは失礼な行動ではなくて
その人にとってそれはまあ知事げることだけなんですね
比べちゃうと そこはそこで問題
トラブルが起こる マーナが現れちゃうと
ですから マーナさえなければ
この世の中でもう何のことなく生きていられるんです
マーナがどこから生まれるかというと
私という化け物から生まれてくるんです
私という化け物はどこから生まれるかというと
眼耳鼻舌身意 この情報来るだけのことです
色声香味触法という情報来るだけで
もう私私はと生まれてくる
その三つもローバの世界に入る
欲の世界に入る ディッティ何か意見捕まってることも
自分と他人を比べることも欲から生まれるんだと
気がひだからやるものじゃないんです
私が好きで比べてみるんですね
比べたところで自分がレベル低いと分かったって
もう気持ち悪くなったっても
本当はもともと自分のこと好きだから比べて比べて比べてみるんですね
じゃあそのセットにはローバのセットと呼ぶんです
ローバトリカと呼ぶんですけど
パーリ語はいいです ローバの三つ
ですから 欲の心にこの三つも生まれる
そこで比べることは この比べる癖がいくらか努力すると少なくすることはできるんです
でも 完全に消すためには
私は私はというその概念はもう消えないとダメなんです
ディッティはまあ誰かにもう
何て言いますか 自分の意見なんかもうめちゃくちゃ壊されちゃったら
もういくらかもう作れないようにもなる
そんなに難しいことじゃないんです
で 悟りの順番で言えばディッティは預流果になっちゃうと消えちゃうんです
マーナはもううるうる残っちゃうんです
預流果になっても消えるわけじゃない
一来果になっても消えるわけじゃない
不還果になってもわずかにうろうろしているんです
阿羅漢になったらマーナが消えるんです
ディッティはもう預流果になっちゃうと
もうないんです もう一つ覚えてほしいのは
この三つも一緒には生まれません
いつでもローバがあの情報を受ける場合は
いいやいいと受ける場合はローバがいつでもある
それでいいものについて何か意見しがみこんで取る時はディッティがある
自分が好きで比べる時はマーナがある
ですから心に生まれる場合はローバとディッティが生まれる
一緒に あるいはローバとマーナが一緒に生まれる
あるいはディッティもなくマーナもなくローバだけ生まれるという三つですね
ものが見て聞いてローバだけだったらローバだけ
欲だけではなくて 意見も作っちゃったらローバプラスディッティ
見 そこで比べたり測ったりするとローバプラスマーナ
マーナとディッティ一緒にはいられない
仕事違い別ですからね
全く じゃあ次のセット
[背景音楽]ドーサ イッサ
マッチャーヤ ウクッチャー
これ 4つあります ドーサ
イッサ マッチャーヤ ウクッチャー
もし疲れてるならばちょっと休んでもいいんです
聞いて疲れてるならば
喋って疲れるならば 私は勝手に休みますと
では一応あの 5分  10分
9時で終わりますね  9時ですね 4
時半 ああそう 休み時間ないんだ
危ないから ドクロ職人に時間間違って行ったんだから
この前行っちゃったな俺
脳ドクロ編行っちゃったんだ
じゃあ休み取り消し で
ドーサ イッサ マッチャーヤ
ウクッチャー これは怒りのセット
すごいわかりやすいんです
ローバのセットっていうのは対象を受けるんだから気持ちいいんです
音楽聴いたら気持ちいいでしょ
明るいんです 美味しいものを食べるとまだ気持ちよくて明るいでしょう
怒りのセットだから反対で暗いんです
そこですごくわかりやすい
そこでドーサから始まります
怒り怒りとよく言うんだけど
また定義はね 定義なければ科学的な知識にはならないんです
科学的な知識こそしっかりした知識なんです
ローバと同じようにちゃんとした定義が必要なんです
ドーサっていうのは また同じ定義で
この眼耳鼻舌身に色声香味触法っていうのは触れると
その対象に認識しちゃうでしょ
どうしても 認識しちゃったんだけど
本当は認識したくない
嫌なんです 拒否したいんです
ですから 受け入れるんじゃなくて
結果として拒否する 音は入るんだけど
音は聞きたくない 口に味が入っちゃったんだけど
その味が味わいたくない
その時生まれるのは怒りなんです
ですから もう私たち一般的に言うと怒りって
その時点ではもう結構違うきめ細かいものなんですね
例えばもうゴム ぐらいの絵を並んで見ているんだと
見ると見ると 1枚でああ
これは綺麗やと見てると 3枚目じゃこれはちょっとどうかなとかね
あるかもしれませんでしょ
これはちょっと気持ち悪いと
という 1番目見て気持ちよかった
2番目見て気持ちよかった
3番目見た時気持ち悪かったって
そこで怒りが生まれた
それで気持ち悪い絵ばっかり見ていると
どうせ自分も暗くなっちゃって
それは恐怖の映画とかあるでしょ
みんな娯楽だと思って見てるんだけど
とことん怒りを作って作って作って
そこで怖くなって やがて震えて
いろんなもう恐怖体験させちゃって
それでお金取ると で このゴテッスゴテスのね
ものを作ったりとかね
そこでどうせ娯楽の世界だから
感情 どんな感情でもいいんですけど
どんな感情でも刺激する
そこでそのすごいこのそういうエイリアンみたいな映画なんか作ったりして
で もう恐怖感作って作って作って
だから見る人々はものすごく心臓はドキドキしてる状態で見て欲しがってるんですね
だから音楽と もうこうやってみたら何のこともないんですけど
やっぱり見る人々はものすごく怖くなって
すごい反応なんですね
そういう まあこれ娯楽だから楽しかったんですか？というと
本人は楽しかったって言うかもしれませんけど
すっごく怒りが生まれて生まれて生まれて生まれて
その感情 ですから怒さというのは
眼耳鼻舌身に入った情報は
これは我々には止まることはできません
音は入る ものは見える
ものは考えてしまっちゃう
その見えたものを 聞こえたものを
味わったものを 触れ合ったものについて
考えたものについて あ
嫌だと思う時は怒さですね
例えば妄想している時は
気持ちいい妄想ばっかりじゃなくて
気持ち悪い妄想もやってるでしょ
それも続けていっちゃいますよ
気持ちいいものを妄想して瞑想もできなくなったとかね
そこで同じく気持ち悪い妄想入っちゃったら
ずーっとやってしまうんです
誰か自分 誰かのことを思い浮かんだとかね
その人のことこんちくしょうと思ったりとかすると
それでその人のことをさらにさらにさらにさらにさらにさらに思って
すると妄想し続けちゃうんです
気持ち悪い妄想だからピタッと止まってくれるかと
そうじゃないんです だからみんなずっと怒りやらずっとそれ持っていくでしょうね
人生 1度でも姑さんと喧嘩しちゃったら
その喧嘩して その恨みをずっと死ぬまで持っていくとかね
で 心の中で妄想して妄想して続けていく
だから感情ですから 刺激ですから
だから結局同じ刺激 漏婆っていうのは受け入れる刺激
怒さっていうのは拒否する刺激
漏婆が生まれると明るいような感じる
明るいように感じる 怒さが生まれると暗く感じる
本当はどっちでも暗いんです
漏婆も暗いんです 明るいのは先心所だけ
で 若手たち一般的には美味しいものを食べたり
美味しい音楽を聴いて
美しいものを見て 楽しく生活
すごく明るくニコニコしているのではないかと
明るいんだ それはもう俗世間のレベルでは明るいんだけど
仏教から見れば暗いんです
それを理解しにくい場合
一つの例があるんです
すっごく欲張ってる人の状態どうですかね
ものすごい暗いでしょ
欲張ることしか能がないんだと
私のうちだ 私の旦那だ
私の子供だとかね 私のお金だとかね
すごい暗い そこでどんどん欲が強烈になったところで
暗いだけじゃなくて 鍵かけてみんな追い出したりするんで
来るなとかって ですから漏婆も暗いです
本当は 怒さも暗いんです
ちょっと我々明るく感じるだけね
とにかく怒さっていうのは
そういうふうに対象は拒否していただいちゃう
何か食べたいなと思って口に入れたら
すごく苦いんだったら
あ 嫌だと出て生まれてくる
それは怒りというんです
ですから 仏教の怒りっていうのは
そういう風に 学問的な解釈で理解してほしい
そう理解しない限りは
怒り怒りと言っちゃうと
みんな全く聞かない 瞑想する時でも
こういうこういうその時は怒りと観察
怒りとラベリングしてくださいと言ったら
本人が怒りでは怒ってないのにと思っちゃうんですね
だから言う通りにやりなさいと大体瞑想で言うんですよ
余計なこと言わないで
その方が一番 ただし 仏教は人を騙せませんから
言う通りにやりなさい
怒りと怒りと確認しなさいと言っちゃったら
怒りで確認した方がいい
なぜならば やがてその真理に出会えますから
別に私は怒っているわけじゃないとまた偉そうなこと言っちゃう
仏教の怒りというのは
この対象を拒否するということである
それは怒り それで OK ワイ
イッサっていうのは何でしたっけ？嫉妬
イッサっていうのは嫉妬
それも当然暗い 嫉妬する